-Welcome back.
President Joe Biden
is joining us.
[ Cheering and applause ]
President Biden,
what did it feel like
the first time
you walked into the White House
as president?
What was the first thing
you noticed?
-What I did notice is that
there is a sense
that you realize
it's not your house,
it's the people's house.
And that sounds corny,
"It's the people's house."
But you realize
that that's the case.
And one of the things
that I find, Jimmy,
and I think you really
would associate with this --
Jill and I feel we come
from middle-class backgrounds.
We both are college graduates
who worked like hell.
We had fathers who didn't go --
Anyway.
The end result was
that we're not used
to people waiting on us.
-Yeah.
And so, in the White House,
you know, there's somebody to,
you know, make your breakfast
or someone to pack your clothes
or someone to carry your bag.
We now have a deal --
and they're great --
the guys who run the kitchen
on the second floor is
we don't have them come in
to do breakfast for us
because there's no need for them
to have to do breakfast for us.
We can make our own eggs
or, you know,
pour a bowl of
-You make your own eggs?
-cereal.
Well, I don't.
Jill does.
I couldn't, you know.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I tell you what.
I'll tell you a true story.
-Yeah.
-When Jill was going
to graduate school,
which was her whole life,
it seems,
[ Laughter ]
when I was a senator,
I'd get home real quickly
and we'd trade off
and my young daughter
would be there
and she'd take off for school,
night school.
Anyway,
to make a long story short,
my daughter was being
interviewed
when she was about, I don't
know, nine, 10 years old.
Said,
"Can you daddy cook for you?"
Said, "My daddy can't do much.
He can boil water
and make psghetti,
but he can't do much else."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, exactly right.
-And guess what -- she's right.
She's right.
-If we talk again, I check in
with you this time next year,
what do you hope we're going
to be talking about?
-I hope we're going to be
talking about how
we've we've gotten COVID more
under control.
I hope we're going
to be talking about how
we have actually reduced
the burden
on middle-class folks
financially,
that salaries continue to go up.
I hope we're going to talk about
unemployment still going down.
I hope we're going to be
talking about inflation
being under control.
But, the other thing, Jimmy,
I really hope that we're going
to be able to demonstrate
that we made worldwide progress
on the environment
because I think it's a critical
thing and pray God --
pray God -- we will have passed
the John Lewis Act
and the Voting Rights Act
because what's going on now
in about 30 states
is literally un-American.
It's about trying to prevent
people from voting,
rather than allow them to vote.
So there's a there's
a full plate,
but I think we can do it.
I'm optimistic about the future
and I'm optimistic
about this country.
We are, as I told everybody,
including everyone from the
leader of China to Russia
and everyone else,
that I don't know anybody
who wouldn't trade places,
a world leader wouldn't trade
places with my job,
versus theirs, because we have
more available to us.
We have more capacity.
We have more science
and technology and decency,
I think, than any country
in the world.
And so I think the sky's
the limit, as to what we can do
in the second quarter
of the 21st century.
[ Applause ]
-Before you go --
[ Cheering and whistling ]
I hope that as well.
I just want to tell you
what an honor it is
to have you on the show tonight.
I'm a very proud American.
Thank you so much
for being here
and, if you ever need me
for anything, don't hesitate.
I am there for you.
-Well, Jimmy, Jimmy,
maybe you ought to come down
and have dinner with me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I'm coming.
I'm going right now.
Alright,
President Biden, everybody.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.
I'll be right there.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪